it's a good afternoon sir I'm going to
talk a little bit about you know how do
we stop to leverage a variety of data
it's so called big data for personalized
health care to truly build a
patient-centered framework and in fact I
was listening to the talk before my mind
and the idea of design big uation and
attaching an ID that would be so much
useful even in the health care you know
if we can deduplicate all the records
and give everyone an all kit ID maybe
that'll be good so if you go back in
time to two thousand and four years ago
and look at the our estimate of national
health expenditures about two point six
trillion dollars two point six trillion
dollars is being spent on our own health
expand our health care and especially
and in this pie chart a special
attention I'd like to draw to the
hospital care and physician clinical
services about 51 percent of this
expenditure is and physician clinical
services or hospital care and that's led
to all the changes that we are seeing as
well in with via Affordable Care Act
whether it's reducing readmission rates
or making accountable care organizations
or patient-centered outcomes research
institutes and what have you so a lot of
the focus is coming on how do we start
to make a dent especially in hospital
care and physician clinical services and
and given that they make fifty one
percent of the two point six trillion
dollars back in 2010 they would even a
small advance in this area would lead to
a significant savings and what's come
about as a result and a quote from AHRQ
is the notion of patient empowerment
that instead of having the I instead of
focusing on a disease or disease
centered model let's focus on the
patient because the disease's do
manifest themselves differently across
the patient groups across each patient
so there is a different progression of a
disease there's a different notion of a
wellness or there's a nifty notion of a
health there's different lifestyles and
environmental factors that go on these
fact go on these things so let's instead
of having a disease centered model let's
advance towards a more of a patient
centered model and in that patient
centered model one of the motivations
has also been how do you empower
what the patient via a dialogue between
the physician and the patient not just a
I walk into my physicians office and I'm
told natash you have this and I saw I
thank you and I leave how do you empower
the patient to actually have a
meaningful dialogue with a physician and
that's actually quite challenging as
well is because the information flow is
often one way and so how do you actually
provide information in the form haja
provide communication in the form where
then it can be a dialogue as a result
where they can be empowerment as a
result and something that I would also
like to highlight here is that a focus
is shifting towards how to make patients
active participants in their own care
and receive services designed to focus
on the individual needs and preferences
in addition to advise and counsel from
health professionals so this idea of
individual needs and preferences and
they can take care and make them active
participants in their own care so when
and and those that's these he sent a few
words or three sentences a sort of the
driving theme of our research program
may be sick can we first understand the
patient better by leveraging the data in
the EMRs and the personal health records
and things like that second can we start
you and personalize the care delivery
model for them personalized a wellness
model for them personalized a chronic
disease management for them and sir and
also provide an interface to whether
it's an it's an ACO a physician or a
nurse or a community health worker to
have a more effective engagement with
the patient now this is all good this
idea of patient empowerment patient
engagement is all good but this is also
not a new idea I 2,000 years ago
hypocrite has said it's far more
important to know what person the
disease has then what disease the person
has and 2,000 years ago he was talking
about patient-centered care he was
talking about less focus on the person
instead of the disease he was talking
about moving away from a disease and
model so the idea is not new it's just
that we have coming to realize it now
via o build maybe the data revolution is
leading us to realize it now from a from
a care delivery perspective so the
driving question of a research as a set
is all about that personalized care
patient engagement figuring out what
other needs how do you suggest what
wellness plans may work understanding
what are my disease risks so we asked a
simple question ask you what are my
disease risks to imagine walking into a
physician's office and at the end of
your visit you actually get a listing on
these are your disease risks and what
you should do about them each one of us
get a personalized assessment from that
perspective not focusing on a disease
per se focusing on each one of us in the
physician's office and in doing so we
can actually start to build what's my
earliest onset of a disease and then I
can start to prevent or intervene early
enough prevention or intervention early
enough will lead to savings in the
hospital services in the clinical
outpatient services etc and there in the
savings lie how do we truly start to
build an earlier onset model so we can
prevent or intervene early enough not
quite for a disease but but more for a
person and why we can do that is because
similarities and shared experiences
matter more than sixty percent of the
factors governing our health and
wellness are related to a lifestyle I
related to our environment yes there is
a genetic component to it but lifestyle
and our environmental factors go and
more than sixty percent of our exposure
to diseases of a progression of diseases
of the comorbidities that we may develop
of all the chronic conditions and have
even managed them so if similar at so
that sort of brings 24 is there
individuals in a large electronic
medical record of millions of patients
whether it's in the health exchange of
the off of washington DC or health
exchange in the state of Indiana where I
am from there's millions of patients
information out there and these millions
of patients information there are people
who share lifestyles who share the
environmental exposures
he went who may share some of the
dispositions they may have to some of
the diseases can we leverage the
similarities and shared experiences and
we do that on a daily basis right I mean
we XO accustomed to recommendations on
movies when you go to Netflix accustomed
to recommendations on music or books
when you go to amazon.com and music and
we go to itunes com so we are accustomed
to leveraging data about all those
people that we have never met but will
trust them to tell us what movie we
should say or what book we should buy or
what music we should listen to you and
we do that all the time we follow that
list of recommendations Ringo yes let
that's great so now I imagine a system
that would tell you just like disease
movies you would enjoy books you would
enjoy welcome Natasha these are the
diseases you would enjoy today and so
that that is the idea of our building
the collaborate or suspend
recommendation engine we are leveraging
the patient information for millions of
patients out there completely dnd
identified no knowledge of who they are
but just knowing what diseases those
individuals have and think about me and
my diseases as me and my books on my
movies oh my are my are my music it's
the same kind of a vector and if
diseases are expressed from a lifestyle
and enjoy mental perspective are those
ghost lifestyle and environmental
factors are expressed in our disease
progression as well so so that's what
we're trying to develop and I'll sort of
tell you a little bit more about what
the system does how it works and and how
we draw inferences and the evaluations
that we have done with it and the pilots
we are running on it so the way it works
is it sort of comes in with an
individual etsy I walk into my
physicians office I walk in with my
individual medical history I compare it
against all the other patients out there
and i compute a similarity score now
computing the similarity is fairly
complicated it's not as straightforward
as one would compute similarities in
terms of movies or music or books so in
this case now netflix asks us to late
movies between 125
and Netflix knows what movies vs you
know if we haven't seen and we know what
movies we have not seen in terms of
diseases I only know what I have been
diagnosed with one and if it's I don't
have the disease in the database that
does not mean I do not have the disease
it could be i have not been diagnosed
with it yet so what does zero mean what
does absence mean and second I don't
remember ever giving ratings to my
diseases hey I like this disease number
five I like this number two I don't do
that and so when so when the rating
system is not there as well so we don't
have that preferential bias towards
movies or books or towards to us
diseases like we have at movies and
books so we basically have a binary feel
I have it and I don't know if I don't
have it that's all we have right so then
how do you construct the the machine
learning or the statistical framework
around it and the second thing that
becomes important in computing the
similarity is so the first database that
we evaluated or algorithm we had a
database spanning over four years from
Medicare between nineteen nineteen
ninety-four ID identified anonymized era
and of cutting million patients over 22
million visits so it was really
longitudinal data for a large number of
patient pool more than thirty percent of
the population at hypotension because of
this because of the age group so just
because I have hypertension I'm similar
to thirty percent of the patients just
on that one disease but that's not
giving me any much anymore value that
you know yes you have how do you compute
a similarity so what and then as a
result of that one strong factor the
relatively rare disease is that I may
share similarity on were not coming to
coming to bear we're not coming to light
so how do you now bring so we give a
higher weight through a relatively rare
disease what is a very common disease
the thirty percent of the population
just happens to share because of one
variable that's constant that's that
similar is the age factor so we had to
think about that perspective as well in
our in a modeling work and then we also
have to think about another company the
scenario when you're competing
similarities is when did I develop a
disease mostly the book the books
recommendation of movies recommendation
don't worry about when in a lifespan
we saw a movie they left they use that
information to build our interest
profile but diseases math if I'm
completing similarity of me to all of
you in the room based on my diseases
when did I you develop something in
verses I develop something so that
timing of disease also becomes very
important at what time and what are the
comorbidities were there before the
ordering the development of the disease
and then you compute similarity on that
basis so we had to truly come up with
all of those factors in developing our
collaborative filtering model where we
had to look at the best match subset
which was looking at a time we had to
look at in the similarity to look at
ones and zeroes how do we compute that
and it was frequency which we decided to
wait the relatively rare disease is
slightly hit a slightly higher than more
common diseases and then we built an
ensemble of these models we built
multiple models because they can be
let's say if I have a disease vectors or
five diseases I could compute similarity
to patients based on all five I could
compute similarity to patients based on
two out of five three or five four or
five or one other side could have
multiple levels of similarity analytics
I could do with my patient with the
patient pool so we did many of those and
we built an ensemble and we basically
took the highest prediction that came
out for a particular disease from that
ensemble because diseases are not
protective against each other so instead
of averaging we went for the highest and
computers cheap so weak and we can do
many of these simultaneously and what
that resulted in was a ranked list of
disease risks so why we focused on a top
20 ranking of disease list was at the
University of Notre Dame we do not have
a school of medicine and the and the way
I started building a collaboration is I
have mo used with the area hospitals and
the health exchange and the clinics and
even now with with schools and we're
doing pilots with independent living
facilities for seniors and with the
community clinics etc so was working
with those physicians and one of my
physician friends commented that i had
these ROC curves and i said look how
sexy my roc curves look and IDK have
such a high a you see we
the other base line models and things
like that he responded saying what
should I do with it because that
physicians incentive was not that the
ROC curves are looking guild and we'll
get a research paper out of it that
physician was not in the school of
medicine physician was a practicing
physician as more worried about how it
helped me deliver care how do i optimize
my day can I see more patients in a day
because of these predictions can I see
let can I go home earlier and see the
same number of patients do I reduce my
the admission rate or do I reduce this
so there were all these other things
that for them more important and as well
as having a list of top 10 or top 20
diseases that I could be at risk for he
said I could eliminate a few of those
because I know things that I would have
been more concerned about those are the
things then sort of become an action
plan and that's the patient empowerment
then that how do you develop an action
plan towards a management so that's sort
of you know led to our progression
towards more of a list approach and even
I'll talk about how we do that
evaluation as well so the data set that
we initially did the evaluation on as I
said was the Medicaid database it was an
inpatient data 13 million patients sorry
two million wizards and was only
icd-9-cm codes we had no other info we
didn't leverage any other information
about in the data we didn't have any
doctors notes we didn't have any lab
results we didn't have any you know any
other biometrics we didn't even have
family information so to speak all we
knew was icd-9-cm codes and then we also
recently acquired 500,000 occupation
data which is spread over 12 years and
this is our patient from a regional
hospital in Indiana and which is spread
over 12 waves and again it has the same
structure as an icd-9-cm code only
nothing else that goes with it and the
way the way the algorithm works is this
is the sort of the overall framework the
overall architecture I presented to you
earlier that can also be presented by
one this master equation but there's a
lot of different computations that
happen here so if I am predicting on a
disease j and i am the active patient a
on whom the prediction is being made i
look at what's the baseline probability
of that disease j for the cluster i fall
in
the cluster I could fall in could be the
based on my demographic could be based
on my family history could be based on
my pre exposure to certain things could
be based on that you know the clinicians
best prior belief assessment on what
that baseline probability is and then we
compute a similarity and you basically
say that how similar am I for this
disease for every patient in the
training data as compared to what the
average scores come out to be and then
we compute this all and then we assign
me a probability of having a disease j
we do this computation for every disease
in the database for every icd-9-cm code
we compute a score for every patient in
the database so every disease is called
every patient is scored now something
else that we do here is unless my this
this is where the the sauce is that when
we compute similarities and we assign a
additional probability if my based on
probability let's say is point two five
and this maximum can go to one point oh
so this can maximum attached or value of
up 2.75 if my Enki is that a gift to a
baseline probability is not
statistically significant I will not
make a prediction so we basically only
make a prediction if it's statistically
significant at ninety-five percent
confidence or the baseline probability
because what our physician friend stole
this is don't tell me something that I
already know and I've already
communicated tell me something that
gives you gives me enough confidence to
create a plan about already I may
already be creating a plan about things
that I can guess I can estimate based on
the prior history so this is again you
know sort of a prognostic more upon
model which is going to talk about what
I may be at risk for developing and then
we compute a iterative version as I
mentioned we complete the ensemble
version out of it and then we also
developed a prime sensitive version as I
talked about where we actually look at
the timing of a disease as well not just
comparing if two individuals have same
diseases when in time did those
individuals develop those diseases so
you also compare that similarity to and
the way we done our experiments here
where we did leave one wizard out leave
one patient Lee one wizard out so for
the 13 million Medicare database we left
one patient out that's a testing patient
as the active a patient that we are
making a prediction on and we predicted
one disease so let's say I'm in the
system with five visits and I take my
visit one I provided to the algorithm to
the key algorithm it makes a prediction
on visit you to visit five and I
evaluate how I create those predictions
were then you know we simulate a
scenario that I go back to the physician
after my visit to so now my dream my
training records visit one wizard to I
used that to compare to all of you and I
make a prediction on wizardry visit for
visit 5 and so on so we do that for
every patient in our database and for
every disease that every unique icd-9-cm
code that exists existed in the database
and so what we could get in terms of a
baseline coverages so the baseline was
thirty two percent which was based on
the clustered I fell in so we created
similarity groups of patients and we
said okay what cluster you fell you fell
in and then we should based on that
cluster was the basement probability of
the disease in that cluster so that was
the best guess up from a baseline
perspective estimate from baseline
perspective and then we developed our be
made a prediction on I care and we get
51-percent of future diseases in the top
20 what that means is of all the
patients in our database on an average
51-percent of an individual diseases
that I would develop in the future we
were predicting in the top 20
predictions and and at us and this is of
course statistically significant and
some of the things that we don't predict
on we don't predict on if we do not beat
the baseline as a statistical confidence
so we basically don't even make that
prediction because that's no knowledge
we don't predict on chronic diseases so
if I've been diagnosed with diabetes and
every time I go and I've been diagnosed
with diabetes yay I'll always get it
correct but we don't predict on that
because it's I have already seen it in
my training vector we don't addicting
progressions wherein I go from four to
point 1 240 2.19
it's something vagina so we only
predicting on the new novel diseases
from that perspective and so we get a
fifth we are able to get that kind of a
coverage which is which is quite
compelling even if it's in talking to a
format from a evaluation perspective
that covering somebody's 51% in the top
20 and if some of these could be acted
upon at the earliest on set such that
prevention of intervention could happen
even for a small portion of the
population that 51-percent of two point
six trillion dollars could be very
effectively contained from that
perspective so and the average ranking
of our predictions was five points 5.6
seven so you know of course you know
some of the things that happen here is
that you know if your computer scientist
you know you also worry about you know
how do we so the algorithm was good we
will be excited by the first set of
results we got but then as you were
scaling it to a bigger population sets
bigger population basis you know it's
comparing similarities across patient
pools across a big disease vector for
everybody is computationally expensive
so and even collaborative filtering
which is what Netflix or Amazon the
family of algorithms that this validates
in books or movies it's also
computationally expensive and the
average number of unique diseases for
our patients is you know well it's up to
nine or a ten so said the number of
unique diseases across a patient loses
also a it's a function of that not only
it's a function of how many patients i
have but how many unique diseases that
exist in the data and now we are also
looking to incorporate prescription
information family history information
and everything else so our similarity
our vector for computing similarity is
only going to increase so we basically
implemented a distributed a MapReduce
table model such so that we could
leverage distributed computing the
skills beautifully and there isn't it
skills beautifully is that my similarity
to all of you is independent of his
similarity to all of you as we have
independent similarity vectors to all of
us so all of us could be an independent
task that could be done simultaneously
and add even and I can do certain
clustering upfront to reduce some of the
compute time for on demand generation of
at a physician's office at the batch
processing way this is really good
in a batch processing of a physician
knows this is my appointments for the
next day dun care the night before and
and provide the recommended disease
risks for everybody in the pool so where
we are going with this is that you're
looking at what the first question that
we started with in our research program
is can we develop something around
patient empowerment patient-centered
outcomes such that for every individual
in the database we can answer one
fundamental question what are my risks
let's face it in a physician's office
I'm not worried about good person next
to me has I'm worried about what I have
so what are my risk you know from a blog
knows from a prospective standpoint and
then what should I do that's also very
compelling is because often the message
is a broadcast message right natash go
home and eat broccoli it's good for you
I hate broccoli please I'll never eat it
even if you tell me 10 times it's good
for me I really don't like it and I'm
being honest about it and so instead
tell me something else that will give me
it eat quinoa you know which is tell me
something which I may enjoy understand
who I am from that perspective what
exercise program may work I work with
community clinics and you know and in
talking to you have become an
anthropologist as well almost now in
talking to the patient population and
you know they're given an antibiotic
there's no refrigeration what's the
point of giving an antibiotic when
little sketch boiled in 24 hours because
this individual does not have a
refrigeration at home or giving somebody
a prescription to go get but a check for
Medicaid has not a social security has
an alive so they can't even go and pick
up the medicine for two weeks or three
weeks so a lot of these factors about
health and wellness or if I am living in
a community where there is no healthy
foods and ghostly shop out there but is
on recreational facility out there those
are the factors which govern a lifestyle
our environment and those are the things
that we are missing an electronic
medical record when was lost a physician
ask you can do you walk you have a
healthy grocery store next door or can
you walk to a recreational facility or
or knowing more about your refrigeration
at home or are things like that right so
those are the things that you believe if
we can start to collect then it becomes
a much more personalized
wellness plan to respond to my risks and
then we got a sustained violence so we
are basically trying to leverage lot of
a socio-ecological model which is built
around a person which is a dynamic
socio-ecological model maybe our social
networks and built and all the other
factors in build and that's that's sort
in a platform that's what we're trying
to do is we have the EMS coming in we're
learning multiple pilots right now we
are bringing in social networks
education recreational information and
nutritional information as well to bring
in a complete story and I'll quickly
tell you about a few pilots that we are
doing so we are going to launch a pilot
the this fall the spring next spring
actually we r ir b process will start
this fall so once the IRB is done
whether you're working with the pregnant
women and one of the challenges we face
and say enjoy county is we have a
relatively higher rates of infant
mortality and what we find is is in the
first trimester a lot of women don't
even see a physician and so do these
beasts you know behavioral factors and
lifestyle factors and everything else
that become important and and we also
collaborating with the center for women
and found the children and families in
in South Bend to even have a first few
years after child's birth so really
building at the continuum from that
perspective and we have partnered with
every day out and that company is giving
us giving us access to content from What
to Expect When You're Expecting book
their digital content we are working
with prenatal care coordinators who work
with these remnants of the idea is that
these the mothers will have the own
mobile technology at personalization
messaging system and all of that which
is linked with your social network
knowledge and and is and the EMRs and
the prenatal care coordinators will have
their own access into what their patient
pool is going so that way it becomes a
two vehicle communication we talked
about the dialogue and the empowerment
we're doing something with a dollar
sense we are working with a middle
school and we're basically doing similar
things about nutrition activity
community and goals and the idea is that
at the back end it's all algorithms and
all our engine about personalization
messaging data moving
they're all the plumbing of data that
has been talked about all the hiding and
things like that in the front and we're
changing the delay to see how does it
work not for obesity for Maduro sensor
childhood perspective we are doing
something with a diabetics population in
a community clinic what does it work for
a chronic disease perspective what
lessons we can learn we're doing it with
a senior population we are working with
we are having two pilots with two
different independent living facilities
for seniors and seeing what we can
interface and how we can pan those
things out so and the reason that we are
doing all these pilots is for us to
truly understand with the most difficult
population that we can work with on the
wide variety of the of the scale what
are the challenges in the last mile when
you talk about translating what
challenges we face and these are some of
the publications have and this is the
email and the website and I've gone over
back two minutes so I we only have two
minutes for questions I guess now thank
you